[Music]
hello everyone hello Uci
hello jean françois hello
everyone welcome to talk about work claude
today we are on episode 2
out of 5 of a series of videos that
aims to explain to you  how to
develop an internet of
things project with the new platform
so today we are going to talk about
advertising my name is jean françois mas crazy
i am a consulting friend in the entity and
next iis services of google cloud
and we are with  the uci will deny that what
brings me back to google cloud yesterday
thank you very much and jean-françois for
the introduction and a few
quick words on pop up globally
pop job is an asynchronous messaging service
therefore which will capture
data and  often send our
messages back
globally in the open source world
this is the closest thing to a
kafka or a rabbitmq puts in
completely manager mode thank you
because you for showing us how
it works but with pleasure yes and
advances to a few small seconds on
the theory to really have the
vocabulary and to understand the mechanism
therefore an application created sends
messages
the public had a thread of messages what
is called a topic
the applications created then
subscriptions subscribers a topic so to
receive messages from this one which
is quite interesting moreover is
that we can imagine all types of
configurations one to many many to one
or even many to many good now
let's move on to  a demo to start
using papsun we are going to create a topic
for that I go to my gcp console
then young people with until pop sum I
click on cries atopique is
16th besides the namespace and by projects
so a mole name and must be  unique
per project in the menu I will then be
able to create subscriptions
export data and even send messages
now in order to automate this a bit
it is also possible  ble to do the same
thing with the command line a
client library in most
standard languages or even via country remai
s for the demo we will happen in a clo
d shell and a cloud and therefore every
hing is done so and I
will have  my command line environment
and utilities already
installed at the same time we will therefore
start by repeating exactly the
same steps from the command line,
therefore the creation of a topic
jack la pop sa taupe et crème and
another topic
then the creation of  a subscription where
we will therefore specify the topic to which
we hang up
with a subscription name we will
then be able to send messages
therefore by specifying the topic and by
specifying the message is from elsewhere we
can also directly read the messages
by specifying the  reception mode
so hen in this case and the
acknowledgment mode so the turn in
this case
now we will do
the equivalent globally from node js
so I have a file  er public who will
send messages for that I
installed beforehand so google
cloud pop job library through an
apn that I will take
we will then simply create a
client define the topic we will use
create a message and the  publish
on the other side we have a file a reef
project which therefore seems to carry the
client library create a client
defines the subscription to use and will
listen for a little while
and besides we see that when we
launch the  'execution we receive the message
we sent earlier that's all
very well but let's imagine that my
project is a hit that millions of
devices send me objects send
me millions of messages how do I
lose  all that but in fact it is
precisely the akp reveals all its
beauty so pop saab is a service
that we will therefore qualify as highly
available highly scalable and with
a very good date years because
can be a service therefore knowing
the  'ess distributed in all our data centers
it's ok that means that I don't
need to manage instances of the
virtual machine that's it absolutely
yes
and after the data will be and leave
so intelligently and
automatically through  the different
data centers of google and if I
need our five priorities in my messages
for example I have a leak in a
refrigerated truck I want to act very
quickly it is more important than
our message from my point of view
how do I  do so most of the
time how we do that is that we will
therefore do topics with different priorities
and then manage the priority on the
application side well that's pretty much it in the
end
so how does it go in terms of
security is this  that you can
tell us a little more about it yes then
security we will retain three main
aspects so we will say the main
data security so like any
service on gc pays its figures and at
rest and in transit
we will therefore also have security
around the use which passes in
particular by the controls of the
access rights therefore on a person or an
application at the level of the product or in
a more granular way and finally finally to
have suddenly what is control  of
this use
so that is to say the use of
log audit logs globally
on read or write admin tasks
thank you uci for all these explanations
for all these demos you can
find and deepen everything that
we explained today in the
resources of this video finally in the
description of the video is moreover
we are going to have a case so spotify which
populate saab intensely 1,700 thousand
messages per second which made a
migration therefore from kafka to pop  job and
who wrote very interesting articles
without government they explain
why they chose pop job and he
also explains the little stress tests
that made us undergo
so I invite you  ite to go and
watch them it's a synth at 100 thank you
super reference so on these beautiful
words we say to you next time
thank you very much
[Music]